قال رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني ان
الاوضاع في العالم تزداد صعوبه والوضع في
فلسطين حساس والتوقعات منذ البدايه تشير
الى تصاعد الامور واضاف في حلقه النقاشيه
على جانب منتدى دافس الاقتصادي ان العالم
مطالب او يطالب اسرائيل بالموافقه على
مسار الزامي ومحدد زمنيا لحل الدولتين وهو
مفتاح الاستقرار السياسي مستقبلا في
اسرائيل والاراضي
الفلسطينيه مسار واحد نشط هو الحديث عن
تبادل الاسرى ووقف اطلاق النار ولسوء الحظ
يتم التدقيق في هذا الموضوع من قبل طرفي
الصراع ومع ذلك نرى انه لا يمكن تجاهل
الصوره الاكبر يجب ان نتطرق الى كيفيه
انهاء الحرب في اسرع وقت ممكن وكيفيه
اطلاق سراح الرهائن والسجناء
الفلسطينيين وما يحدث في الضفه الغربيه لا
يقل سوءا عن غزه ولا نرى رد فعل حقيقيا من
المجتمع الدولي تجاه ذلك نتساءل دائما
ماذا لو ان هذا السلوك وهذه التصريحات اتت
من دوله اخرى هل سيكون المجتمع الدولي
صامتا هكذا لا اعتقد ذلك علينا ان نتحمل
المسؤوليه ونعالج الازمه الحقيقيه باعطاء
الفلسطينيين دولتهم وبطرح يجعل الجميع
ملزمين بذلك خصوصا اي قياده سياسيه قادمه
في
اسرائيل